robbed face off no more drugs for that
man we want this movie look at this film
and we're done that's it's like no this
will be some easy my god when this with
its good not doing that dark period of
films - yeah I would have been a dope
good summer no junior in high school
maybe senior hmm I want to say was a
junior high school is like the summer
like a ninth grade yeah and it just this
blew my high school my he was so it just
this movie was oh my foot this is one of
those films where it's like it's totally
stupid but there's all there's this
phenomenal passion behind it and you can
tell even though it's all over the top
and it's really silly the filmmakers
really care about what they're doing
like all the acting is over there
wrapped in totally committed
ridiculousness they're like we're really
gonna show the drama of this it's just
our perception Rama is really
over-the-top and goofy but we're still
gonna like try to show it so like when
people die they really die when you know
bloody things happen they really happen
and when the action scenes happen they
won't make them as big and friggin
phenomenal as possible uh so yeah this
is one of those films where it's like
it's you know reminds me of it's like
it's kind of like Batman da tamanna made
series except there's no shadows in it
it's all brightly colored and everything
but it's that same thing where it's like
it's kind of like a cartoon but they're
really trying as well but someone forgot
to tell face off that's not a cartoon to
our advantage there was a gray line I
think Siskel had about a what was it
Mission Impossible I know your time and
he was talking about at Tom Cruise and
Siskel said I'm not always sure what it
is Tom Cruise is doing but he does it
with such passion and vigor that I'm
totally invested in whatever it is I
don't know he's definitely I think he's
faced off kind of works the same way
it's like I'm not sure any of this makes
any any fucking sense but they are so
invested in it that you just can't help
but just get sucked along for the ride
yeah I think you have a mission Pollux I
don't know what
Cruz wants but he wants it so bad yeah
that's kinda same thing here it's like I
don't know what's going on but it just
it wants to entertain us so badly that
I'm willing to just accept it
this was the film you know for a long
time maybe it's still going on I don't
know but in high school when kind of
that goth thing was happening a little
before that people start wearing the
long black hose I was like just kind of
style say it was mostly kids that
thought they were email that they
usually weren't uh and I I warn so I
could say that one it's not free matrix
no no that you're saying yeah no I got
it from a face I saw cuz why Susie steps
out of that car and that black coat is
floating in slow-mo in the wind I'm like
I just fell in love with that I'm like
it's funny it's funny because like so
many people I know like our age are just
like they it's either I know people my
age or older and it's always like you
got the trench coat kind of thing either
from Tim Burton's Batman if you're older
than us or or if you're slightly younger
than us the matrix or Dark City or or
bleh that was another one yeah coats
were and then on the wheel Gmail got it
from face off we got from face off
greatest action movie face off
I need a tombstone for me too um those
are the two and the but I will say blade
cemented it for me that's where I'm like
okay I wanna work a curette ya know they
were the blonde black coats and
everything um but yeah that I mean
that's what was for us uh but yeah this
it's just all the people that are so
over-the-top and silly just with no
filter that just like do the thing that
we love to see you do with John Travolta
Nicolas Cage and John Woo just do it go
have fun
it's like the turtle go play a gangly
Zach said was thick enough then he's
just like do it everyone I'm sorry ha ha
ha ha you racist fuck they all know each
other though I'm sure ok why not it oh
the Hulk
yeah no to be fair no no and John Woo
made some very bad
action films after faceoff uh why don't
know did he you had I get off use all
around cuz then there was a Mission
Impossible - yeah no no cuz you have
Mission Impossible - and that sucked but
that's kind of fun and how bad it is um
and then I don't know what he did after
that because he had broken arrow before
face off he's obviously a huge action
martial arts director um so it's one of
those things where it's like he kind of
disappeared after Mission Impossible -
or no no he made like a war film was a
Windtalkers or something like them that
oh yeah uh so yeah after that it's like
I don't know where he went
I'm sure I can look at IMDB maybe he's
still making a great living I don't even
know if he needs to I'm Shelley wait
I've moved John Woo and the martial arts
are amazing distraction um but yeah you
mistake that's above oh nice try try to
yeah should I get over to me I see you
know what maybe they'll still get angry
at you anyway they're so used to yelling
at you there's something I disagreed
with in your wait watching video um but
yeah I think it's it's one of those
films where it's like how can we just
take these actors okay well I think into
closed cage all I get is craziest I get
vampire's kiss um one or two of those
free cats but I just think like run the
gamut just Caelius over the top weirdest
faces it's like the most oh the my
consistently he's not like this is
normal throughout the most don't know
what love is a free the thing I love
about this movie for Nicolas Cage
performance you don't have to wait for
the crazy yet is literally the first
shot of the movie where he's like
totally like making out with some like
choir girl like it you all right oh yeah
oh yeah you you don't have to wait at
all it just watches straight into it um
whereas other movies like with crazy
Berea we go in Wicker Man we there's so
many others where it's like yeah the
performance is crazy but you have to get
there you have to be patient and I don't
want to be patient sock Sally from that
burger I don't want to be I want the
adventure now I want to see Nicholas
Cage you have a fucking break down now
um and it's it's
one of the most satisfying Nicolas Cage
performed really it gives you exactly
what you was just crazy the whole
beginning that John Travolta you know I
mean this is a dude who a lot of times
goes over the top he's still trying to
be serious I really feel like with this
it's just that every perfect mix of like
totally batshit crazy but also dramatic
somehow and fun yeah he is is caged in
one sense had the advantage in that he
can be crazy to start with and then when
he's playing the Travolta role he can
still be a little crazy because it's
obviously a good guy and a bad guys body
and it drives him a little mountain he
has to pretend to be nuts
Travolta starts off his characters kind
of bland he's like that everyman us yeah
martial cop that never goes to sleep at
the five o'clock shadow guy's afraid you
and the kids rings do you know that was
it when the case breaks but the second
he has to play Nicolas Cage like I enjoy
it just as much
watching Nicolas Cage it's just a shame
you can't actually see John Travolta as
Nicolas Cage go up against Nicolas Cage
as Nicolas Cage that would have been
amazing haha but if I'm gonna get a
sequel every line he delivers with just
such he just savers it's you know what
it is to what I really like about it is
that I can even though they're not
they're not doing impressions of like
the voice cuz that that would be too
silly but they it's their own flexions
down yeah so well on each other and I
love actors that can do that when they
have to play opposite each other and
they have to imitate the other but they
do it was like I can completely see I
think the other thing he does is the way
Nicolas Cage kind of moves his head a
bit and says things very slowly yeah I
mean they're both it make us they're
both already kinda similar when they
have to have their freak outs and their
cool smooth moments I mean they're
already kind of similar but you can
still tell when one is imitating the
other it's like no no he's he's caged
now John Travolta is doing cage he's not
doing Travolta
um Papa's got a brand new
oh this movie is so quotable - how many
times have we said I give you a page for
our Oh God I know my favorite is still
would like you show up sometimes like
unannounced and I'll literally look at
you me like Sasha what the fuck are you
doing Marla or wood things are getting
like really bad she crazy I'll just be
like hey whatever - oh is it in this
religious you're still not a meek Eddie
fine outside this is all we're gonna do
the rest of the where's the video we're
just gonna quote this damn movie cuz
it's so beautiful um yeah I just feel
like this is your son wasn't personal
you know what it feels no it was an
accident but you took it so personally
why couldn't you move on and kill
yourself Haji annals what was it no uh
no father could no brother could either
neither could a sister it just keeps
going but that's not Mexican standoff is
yeah no good man just more and more
people keep getting attitude and that's
what I love it's it already starts off
big but then you feel like they just
keep adding more and more in a way that
you can follow you know perfectly well
and it flows strangely enough of course
the typical John Woo trips why they're
fucking doves in a church I mean I am
but what I'm gonna go to church and sit
in bird shit so she's up at that close
the window close the god I don't care if
the curtains look pretty if they're
blowing in slow motion it's cold um you
know it feels like an 80s movie like one
of those Robocop eighties movies that
can go balls to the wall can be
over-the-top like Wall Street action
that's only way I can describe it I
don't like it I almost feel like it's
the last in a stranger kind of eighties
movie even though it came out and like
was a ninety seven ninety some late
night but if you're right it does have
that total feel of just like we're just
gonna give you wall-to-wall action it's
gonna be batshit crazy it's I mean it's
a hard our movie and one of my favorite
like hard are movies they do not fucking
hold back at anything which of course
now everything's like PG fuckin 13 but
now they're gonna try and make stuff are
that doesn't need to be
work as a Deadpool but okay look I'm not
gonna go there I'll just have Deadpool
fans
it's just now my throat and I already I
already have Angley and John Woo
hahahahahaha
okay so like even Deadpool I felt was
pretty light and fluffy hmm for an arm
movie there's a couple into there I love
the cimoli torturing him and like II
can't breathe' no his face looks like
you know is shriveled up avocado but for
the most part I'm just like yeah don't
get me wrong I enjoyed the hell on a
Dead Pool like I I know you talked about
what there's a lot of things I loved
about but one of yeah particularly came
to the gore in the blood side I thought
the sex was fine but when it came to the
like the gore said I was it yeah it felt
pretty tame to me I really wasn't that
I'm like it it was so cartoony it just
yeah it's it's an R but it to me it just
doesn't compare with some of the hard
our movies in life and I love it and I'm
really not going on on about it you know
a hell with CG or anything it's more
like just when you see the blood
actually happened right there and you
have to do gore effects not really right
it just looks more Julie and it feels
more real and it just makes you a bit
more uncomfortable which is what you
know I like looking for in an RFIC GI
blood just did
it's like goofy but but I get it it's a
comic book movie it's Deadpool you have
to have fast action with this blood in
these weird stuff going on any totally
give me Kill Bill blood splatter
everywhere give me Sam Raimi blood
splatter give me what well that that
Gore I even count as gore I mean that's
all meant to look super fake even though
it is really there I'm not afraid or
like Sweeney Todd or something is but
honestly though I enjoy that more than
CGI blood like I'm like well it's still
there and like it I don't know I can't
with that well but I know you're talking
about we'd already on a rant the point
is I really really love Deadpool but I
just love the heart our quality to this
film yeah uh even the surgery on the
face oh I guess we shove it in high
school
I was just like oh yeah no that's still
one of those things where it's like
helps out no face bra bra bra fucker now
no no you got away for his little screen
Oh regarde fuck but it's cool
let's go we're gonna go up oh we're
gonna get up yeah we're just gonna make
the doctor's is like what do you want
like you just see the reflection of no
face in this glasses like take one
fuckin girl that the place is movie the
funny thing is if you do go and pause
those scenes as of course we did the
quick little snippets they have of him
applauding why it shows us his face it's
like yeah it looks pretty fake oh but it
is but when you're in the moment like on
the big screen you're like oh you know
know the audience we said it was like oh
yeah um oh oh shit this movie just love
this movie I'm sorry uh what else can we
even say about it you know uh I'll say
this about all of the you know what I'll
say what do you say this again the side
characters it's a that's enough you're
like Whitey's movie like an 80s movie
80s movies were filled with great
character actors you watch were side
characters yeah like there's one problem
I have with today and it's not I'm not
gonna single out only today because I
feel like there's a lot of films I've
even seen in the 50s and sometimes 60s
and then the character actors can be
really great but you know there was some
times in Phil where side characters just
seemed disposable like they're there's
no real performance just they're there
to deliver a few lines move on are there
to be like good role models or something
like that
80s films is like everybody was a weird
fucking character like I think of
ghostbusters I think of Batman I think
of like Robocop it's like every side
character you almost you want to know
every side characters your you know so
much with those other decades in film
the side characters are exactly that
they're to the side they're there to
serve a purpose a goal there a you know
for like a better term a tool they're a
tool to serve the story or something you
want to feel a little three-dimensional
but they're mostly just there as a tool
to serve the story yeah in the 80s it
feels like wow these people could exist
even after the movies over yeah and I
think with face off it's the same thing
all these side characters you know just
you feel like they can exist outside
only fair and I thought I will be fair
to the 90s I think a lot of that still
carried over
like when I think of like bland or sad
really nice ease early nineties not even
land again I feel like I don't know even
when even when I think about something
is that I don't even love like well now
I'll have them down my throat
Independence Day which it's past we
entertaining but I'm like I still
thought the side characters were they
managed to everybody managed to kind of
have a personality I feel like you
someone they are such annoying stereo no
oh no they totally are
Oh God except for Smith he's only what
all the others I'm like I still feel
like blowing the plan okay okay
I still feel like the 90s had a better
grip on it then now though there's so
many movies I see where like you know
the side characters I think I gave it
just kind of depends yeah I don't know
but I know what there's so much story
now in movie some good some bad but
there's so much story I kind of get like
yeah okay we just have to do so much now
because we have to make room for the
five movies we're gonna do after this
you know that you can always have these
characters or like the side characters
are gonna are gonna have their own
movies now as well you know I'm thinking
mostly about the Marvel stuff and the
comics no no I think I think at least
half the Marvel movies managed to make
good use of the side characters late
especially and in a way where they're
interesting yeah there's some that don't
and then I'd obviously the DC ones
recently don't I had a Batman vs
Superman outside of Alfred ood
well I'm Wonder Woman we wanted to see
more of her no but I mean like yeah but
she's gonna get her own way I'm talking
about like Lois who doesn't have a
personality must be a main Harry yeah
Jimmy Olsen there for one second nobody
gave a shit you know Perry White
I did but what I was gonna say with what
John Woo is that something he did well
uh phrase he quoted I think I'm like man
that what a beautiful phrase is he said
the by the ballet of violence and I
thought what a beautiful way to put that
cuz we see how he shoots his action
sequences I mean this was one of the
guys who would move the camera as the
action was happening at its circle
around get these above shots loans yes
and he was shooted in trenches but it
were beautiful I mean it's like I wish I
knew I would tell this is what baekeland
you could sell like bay saw this said I
I like that I want the constant movement
the constant stuff but he didn't and
sometimes the shots can be very well
composed but he didn't think about
you know how long do you hold out the
graceful elegance of it how good it
looks instead it's just quick cuts quick
cuts movement moving with it you know
it's waving your keys instead of
watching this beautiful ballet and what
kills me is he's now one of the better
examples like he's actually more in the
upper echelon of well I guess that's not
that bad compared to his imitators now
hmm but how sad is that
imitators a BAE yeah yeah like no I've
seen movies where I'm like this is like
a Michael Bay imitation and it's scaring
me that there are times I'll sit through
me like god I wish I had BAE like look
I'd be lying if I said I said that much
but maybe you see more bad action oh no
like there's some action scenes I've
seen where I'm just like the shaky cam
we still hate you know in movies but
there's no shaky cam and as you can see
it all but it's still constantly moving
there's still constant motion and the
editing is just the right amount of we
shake it out and appreciate the shot I
wish I knew what the thin like gray line
was because like I look and I'm like I
mean come on this somewhere over the
rainbow song playing like is the kids
listening to these somewhere and like
all of this violence unfolding to that
song and I'm like this is literally the
most pretentious thing they really and I
like and I don't know why it works
because if some other director had done
this like how easy I would have been
like this is stupid but for some reason
when John Woo did it it actually works
which is funny because when John Woo
does shit in like Mission Impossible - I
actually hated it you know what it is I
guess it's just a time in a place and
this was the time and I'm thinking of
something like you know like Moulin
Rouge or something like that where it's
like it's someone obviously is
pretentious but they're trying to say
something do you get what I'm saying do
you get what I'm saying and sometimes I
can really where a lot of times I can
really work other times you just feel
the pretension is more here it feels
like he wants to do it because it's
beautiful yeah but here's the horrifying
thing with that like when it comes to
Moulin Rouge still watch that over
Phantom of the Opera
alright that's tough for me but no
contest I'm like I mean I totally
understand Booya Moulin Rouge is the
better crafted movie hands-down and it's
not matter and I am completely
indifferent to that film I'm not really
a huge fan to move on Rouge but I'm like
it's the same thing as like the Michael
Bay thing I was like oh that's like it
when you see a film that's that bad when
you
just like well I'd actually take michael
bay's action directing over that's it's
like you've hit rock bottom
um and yeah I think there's there's
something to that when somebody and I do
like action movies now I think they're
being done pretty well but there is
something it's like when you're gonna do
action you just you want to see the
action or move the camera a little bit
or you all go overboard like Michael Bay
where the camera goes under the wheels
and over around it it's so fake it
doesn't look like it's there to me it
really feels like when John Woo does an
action film he wants it to be a movie a
visual experience something that's
impressive him like we fucking did that
we went there not only do we do this
incredibly impressive thing but we shot
it in a beautiful way and it has a story
huge and gigantic that matches that
insanity the old-school action films
were like that it reminds me of a
Cameron film where like the at the
scenes are just or even like like I'll
give Spielberg credit like I I didn't
like lost world but the action set
pieces put together great like and
that's something I feel like we've lost
I feel like we're getting it back
finally um as people I kind of take a
step back and be like oh you know we can
really shoot action scenes set things up
show you everything but those films like
face off like a lot of James Cameron's
work like Terminator 2 like older
Cameron like Titanic are pretty Titanic
like it was more about like the
spectacle and it was like we're gonna go
to all this work to put this shit
together we're gonna fucking show it G
yeah we're gonna show it like like I
watch things I'm like there's all this
work put into these scenes and the
cinematography is terrible you can't
make anything out they CGI a thousand
effects and lens flares and shit over it
you know you can't make anything out I'm
like what the fuck is the point then mmm
um so yeah what else can we say mmm
suspicion what else do we say about face
i it's just so much fun it's so much fun
it is fun fun boozy turning into a real
merry
yeah funny lines as what I had a good
sense of humor it could be really dark
and gritty like you have a good sense of
humor too I mean it's just such a fun
action to fill every character is uh
interesting I like I like this
life I liked his daughter and she's all
like totally into it when she's being
shown how to use the knife yeah she's
like okay okay I mean that's both a very
scary but kind of funny moment that
she's just getting so into it I like I
liked Roy's brother mm uh you know the
kind of the nerdy one like I um what's
his face that's above the bald guy that
said no more drugs for that man and
stuff uh the head of the DA's office or
wherever he was worried that he was in
Fargo
yeah back Amy ciao I am pretty happy
isn't that her as what every single
character in this movie is just
interesting even if they're killed off
in the first ten minutes like I feel
Ajith Amelie bad when those people got
killed but when Travolta killed those
people after he got the face uh you know
a Cage's face or whatever swishing
around and they burned him alive and you
see him game bernama I'm a legitimately
that I'd like to look an undercover uh
stewardess in the beginning on the plane
like like shoot sir Jesus your body goes
rolling down the runway and I'm like
yeah dirt dirt dirt dirt you do like is
a thing I'm like wow she had like a
two-minute roll I was like I feel bit
like I'm gonna miss her I feel like I
feel like those films were kind of
harder core but you feel the
consequences of it like get a pg-13
movie you want to blinked hmm like but
that's what I enjoy about like you know
give me like I shouldn't say give me a
film for fuckin adults but cuz it's so
silly but yeah it's for fucking adult
it's a Cecilia dult movie it's for adult
children it's yes it's for adults that
want to feel like kids again but want
the perks of being an adult yeah we want
the blood we want the violence but we
want to be adventurous and fun and goofy
and you know stuff like that I really
feel that this is what those movie got
its in you're right it straddles that
line between like because it feels like
an eighties in but I will say this it is
so 90s
yeah well especially with the long coats
I mean yeah like it is so 90s but I'm
when I think of an example of a great
90s movie cuz I get shit sometimes
people just like you always about the
80s are 30 good nineties movies I'm like
oh hell yeah like there's always
actually I love Durant I love Jurassic
Park still so the movie I've seen the
most in the cinema so I'm at seven
fucking times but like this is a great
example of like one of the greatest 90s
movies ever made mmm so yeah
no it's a lot of fun uh you know and
even with like mission impossible to you
know I think to myself man if this was
not a Mission Impossible movie maybe it
could have warts and it's still kind of
the scabs that they're still kind of a
maybe because I mean the doves
constantly everywhere in the musical
change well I'm like okay you you don't
have to show it to support this but you
know I still respect the passion you're
but it's it's the argument and I
disagree because I didn't hate the
Abrams Trek film like a lot of people
did but I get that arguing just like
well this just doesn't fit
Star Trek hmm and I I do get it even
though it it was fine for me but and I'm
actually a big Trek fan so I'm not
saying that as a tourist hmm
but I get where they're coming from
because when it comes to Mission
Impossible I totally felt that way about
Mission Possible - it's like I don't
hate you whoo like faceoff is one of my
favorite action movies it's just this
just did not feel like Mission
Impossible though I think it was miscast
yeah well as much as Angley directing a
Hulk yeah no ha ha I brought it together
no no but but here's the thing with
face-off
the emotions and the drama is big I mean
you know these families you know they're
people you know the side characters so
that when this happens these two as the
yin and yang these two opposites are
suddenly switched and they're in
different work this is a big story it
was made possible it's a spy film trying
to be a big story but they never got the
meat of it or what's in trance Ari a
sequel got what made Mission Impossible
yeah even if you take out this mission
and possibly just a spy movie and that's
all you call it or something the fact
that they didn't have a big enough story
or characters you warned like that you
wild it - because like when you just
went through that description it is one
of the most perfect comic book movies
there are comic book movies that wish
they could do this cuz this is epic good
versus evil yin yang one side becomes
the villain you might say the Batman
animated yeah it would make it would
have made a great graphic novel can't
tell you that um so somebody draw that
at you it would be really good except
would just be like I wish so far to the
movie uh but ya know it's uh I can't I
can't think of a problem okay the only
problem with this film what
what is this what what what is that what
bobert what is that who does that well
Rob don't you see it's taking his face
off
he's playing his face on oh yeah how you
like um but no it's uh who does that I
you know on screen it looks really
charming oh yeah but if it's done in
real life it's like that's really
annoying I can I've been on plenty of
first dates in my life I can't ever
imagine like trying that on somebody
that I was ever trying to see yeah we're
just I get trip I wouldn't try that on
my own wife hey honey
we know I wash it with her one's eyes is
like do you like that like and she's
like don't ever do that yeah I guess
you're saying what is that I don't know
it's like the one thing in the movie
it'll be like the symbol that like winds
his wife back over or whatever but yet
still oh no and I told my girl works out
under everybody that they just do it
it's like oh that's cute like no no like
this is kinda you know what I you know
what I love about that it works on her
because I'm like well I I get it now
because no other human being on the
planet like their right mind would ever
fucking do that then the sister does it
to the new little boy that they adapt
because they do the command I'm just
waiting is your new mommy and you see
this we are your new parents um that was
so eighties to adopting the kid at the
event 80 but still felt right in this
universe that you created the comic book
universe yeah I just yeah I was waiting
for that kid just be like don't moment
that that annoys me yeah it's got you
know it's like dark man it's a comic
book movie that's not actually a comic
book I feel that would be another great
exist another example of one of the
greatest comic book movies ever made not
based on any property yeah uh so now
it's current scene it just it is in bait
right face off isn't based on
oh no that's original original yeah I
know it is so much fun really an idea
yeah it really is
stupid stupid it's but in the most
Italian t'v ways that they utilize and
totally embrace it like everything you
can do with that idea too
almost to a fall where you can be like
well this is so over the top and I think
that's part of the fun um so if you
haven't seen it go it's so enjoyable
what are they so crazy just so over the
top it's the best one of the best 90s
movies ever made but I think of a movie
that's a blast you know they always put
that movie it's a blast it's like what
are you talking about like this is a
film that feels like a blast I be it's
just such overload but in the best way
um so yeah go check it out and have your
face oh oh yeah